I'm really happy that the Enhanced Games actually happened.
A lot of people say it failed, but not in my opinion.
In my opinion, it did something really good, because it showed us a lot of truth about sport, and maybe it can help destroy this bubble of belief we have about the condition of today's sport.
I prepared a short PDF about this that we can dig into, so you can form your own opinion.
And I'm going to share with you what I think about this whole issue.
So for those who don't know what the Enhanced Games were, basically it was like the Olympics on gear.
They allowed professional athletes to compete under medical supervision and to use performance-enhancing drugs.
We have some categories here, as you can see. I also added a small legend, so we can see, for example, an official current or former world record holder. So Thor Bjornsson is an R, which means he holds or held a world record. And as you can see, there are a few of them, so these are not random people.
Here we have another one.
Okay.
O stands for Olympic participant, which obviously also shows us the level of the athlete.
M means world or continental champion, as you can see, and K means national champion.
And C means competitors who were natty. I mean, they claimed they were natty. They were not under the enhancement protocol.
So it's pretty important to say that these were pretty good athletes.
Maybe they were not always the best of the best, but as you can see, we also have some world record holders, which is elite.
Okay, so we have protocols.
The performance-enhancement protocols for individual athletes were not stated.
So we only know what percentage of them used what, but we don't have protocol by name.
Obviously, testosterone, growth hormone, stimulants, EPO, these are, I think, the most important things. EPO for endurance, obviously. And it is also worth mentioning that they allowed swimming suits that are not allowed at the normal Olympics, and that can also influence performance a little bit.
Yeah, here we also have the table for the pills that were used.
Okay.
So there was only one guy who went faster than the world record. Obviously, it's not official.
We have three guys who won and were not on PEDs, which is interesting.
Yeah, okay. But in general, those who say it failed mean that there were not many guys who pushed the ladder or pushed the bar higher in the sport. That was the main goal of the Enhanced Games, and that's why people say it failed: because we don't have many world records.
Even those who were world record holders did not beat their own world records. So okay, here I also have tables for the best result, which is the world record, and what the best result in the sport actually was. As we see, the world record is always higher. Now we have the same table, but in numbers.
And here it is for the weightlifting categories, right?
So only one thing was done better.
Okay, so some people will say, "Okay, but they were not in their peak, they were not the best, or maybe they were just too old," or something like that.
That's why I included these tables here.
They show the times, the average times, or which events these athletes were participating in, and how it relates between them. So for example, in the one hundred meters, there were two participants with a World Championship reference and one with an Olympic reference.
That means at least two guys from this Enhanced Games race were also at a very high Olympic or world level.
So as you can see, these guys were pretty much at this level. And we also have the times, but that's not very important.
Here we have their PRs, right? Their personal bests, and what they did at the Enhanced Games.
And that is also interesting, because many of them did worse than they had done before.
Some of them did better. So actually, there were some guys who beat their personal bests, but not all of them.
Medical supervision. In general, they were not allowed to hurt themselves with PEDs, and that may be something worth commenting on. Because someone will say, "Okay, but if someone was twenty-five years old and now is forty, obviously he was better before." So I also checked the ages and linked the age when the personal best was made with today's age.
So actually, there are guys, for example, I think it was this one, yeah, this guy was twenty-five, which is pretty much in his peak, and he was better before, without enhancement, than he was two years later after enhancement.
Okay, so we have the same situation here, where a guy without enhancement was better than with enhancement and was pretty young. We exclude this guy, for example, and this guy, but we take the guys who are actually in their peak. So as you can see, it is pretty mixed. Some did better.
Okay, this one did better. This one did not do better. Oh no, this one also... Yeah, I messed up.
But some of them did better and some of them did not. If you want, pause and go through it.
But it's not really important. The general picture is what is interesting for us. And in weightlifting, obviously, nothing interesting happened.
So what we are taking from these tables right now is that some of them beat their personal bests, and some of them did not.
And we can sum it up, because we have gone through all the tables, which were a bit boring, I think.
I hope not.
But in general, you can see that we can make the conclusion that enhancement doesn't work.
And even if enhancement works, those enhanced guys were not able to beat those natural champions, those clean heroes.
And that saves our faith in today's sport.
So I collected studies that actually prove that performance enhancement works.
And I'm not going to go through all of them. I will just mention two, because one says it actually didn't do much. But to be fair in this video, because I found this study, I didn't want to remove it just because it doesn't fit my idea.
The problem is that I found a meta-analysis showing the contrary: that the sample in this study was just too small, and it didn't show a result because it was not very good. Even so, I read it, I found it, so I put it in my PDF.
So this is the one that was worth mentioning.
Even though, as I said, the meta-analysis said there is a correlation between fat-free mass and human growth hormone.
And I'm going to discuss this one, because it's one of my favorite studies.
Actually, there were four groups, and I have this on the second screen.
There was testosterone and lifting, testosterone only, lifting only, and placebo.
Okay, so obviously testosterone and lifting was the best.
In terms of building fat-free mass, testosterone and lying on the couch was better than lifting, and placebo was at the end.
Strength was a little bit different.
Obviously, we have massive gains here for testosterone and training: thirty-eight kilos added to the squat and twenty-two kilos added to the bench in ten weeks.
And for testosterone only, we have sixteen kilos for the squat and nine kilos for the bench.
And for lifting only, we have twenty-two kilos for the squat and thirteen kilos for the bench.
So in general, natural lifters got stronger faster than the testosterone-only group, but the testosterone group built three point two kilos of muscle mass, and the natural lifters built two point eight.
And why did natural lifters get stronger?
Because hypertrophy was quite similar here, but obviously those guys were lying on the couch and just blasting testosterone. They didn't stimulate their nervous system, and strength is also the capacity of the nervous system. So even apart from muscle hypertrophy, the strength gain from muscle hypertrophy was probably similar, but the natural lifters got extra from nervous system adaptation.
So we have two contradictory things.
We have studies showing that performance enhancement works, and it works greatly, because twenty-two kilos versus thirty-eight kilos on the squat during the same protocol, with the same kind of people, the same control group, and the same time, is a massive difference.
It's almost twice as much.
And obviously, we need to remember one thing: here we have testosterone, but people are not taking testosterone only.
This is like the base, right? There are extras on top of it.
So we have two contradictions.
Performance enhancement is well known for working. That's why it's banned.
And we have the Enhanced Games with pretty elite guys, and they are not doing better than the other guys. So what's the problem?
We can leave it like that and say, "All right, we stay in our bubble, and we believe sport is clean and these guys are just not that good."
Or we can face the truth and say, yeah, because everyone is on PEDs, right?
Everyone is doing that.
The Olympics are a performance-enhanced event.
Every single sport in the world is enhanced.
And why don't you see the difference?
Because maybe the protocol they have is less effective than the one they had in previous competitions.
If you are enhanced and you are not able to beat the personal best you did two years or one year before, what happened?
You lost your shape? All of them?
All of them? Especially in strongman or weightlifting competitions, which are greatly connected to anabolic steroid use.
Because endurance is a little bit different, right?
But what about this?
What about the strength disciplines?
Why did nobody do it?
When the correlation is visible, it is just clearly correlated with steroids in the studies.
So you can take whatever you want from this, from the Enhanced Games.
In my opinion, it did a really good job, because finally we can show the world, we can say: look, sport is not clean.
There is no clean sport.
We can agree with this and say, okay, we stay with unclean sport, and we are fine with that.
Or we find better ways to fight performance enhancement. But we cannot pretend we are blind anymore, because we have it in black and white on paper that everyone in every professional sport is on some kind of enhancement. And one or two guys you can write about in the comments, "Yeah, but he was..." It doesn't matter. It doesn't change the whole picture, unfortunately.
This is what we have in sports today, and the only question is how we approach this thing.
If we accept this, maybe we should draw the line for what is accepted and what is not.
Or maybe we shouldn't draw the line.
Like in armwrestling, no one cares.
You do whatever you want, and we have these superhumans, right?
Because we like watching them, and it is only their responsibility for their bodies.
But on the other hand, do we want sport to be that destructive for the athletes? This is a hard topic.
You can say in the comment section what you think about that.
Which approach should we take?
But in my opinion, the most important thing is that the discussion should start here.
Are we going in this direction or that direction?
But we cannot pretend anymore that we are blind.
And yeah, the Olympic Games are, in fact, the Enhanced Games.